Loree Laughlin's daughter Olivia Jade's
alleged fake crew resume released et has
obtained a copy of the resume that was
apparently submitted to the University
of Southern California the document
filed last week by federal prosecutors
claim said Olivia won multiple awards as
a crew athlete even though it's alleged
that she never participated in the sport
I want them to be happy so I want to be
supportive of everything they want to do
but I do want them to have somewhat of a
normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I would really want
that for them the alleged resume claims
that in 2014 and 2016
Olivia won gold medals at the San Diego
crew classic and claims she won a silver
medal at the same sporting competition
in 2015 it also alleges that in 2016
Olivia participated in the head of the
Charles Boston one of the world's
largest rowing events and came in 11th
place and that she competed at the event
again in 2017 and came in 14th place the
document also lists her supposed skill
set as a coxswain the steersman of the
ship's boat which includes awareness
organization directing and steering the
resume also reads quote she is highly
talented and has been successful in both
men's and women's boats I just want them
to have that experience and get that
education and have a degree to fall back
on the fuller house star and her husband
Massimo are accused of paying five
hundred thousand dollars in bribes to
get their daughters admitted to USC as
recruits for the crew team even though
neither of them had ever participated in
a sport I think the likelihood that
Lorrie spends prison time is very very
high because of the seriousness of the
crime and the amount of money that we're
dealing with here
both Lori and Massimo have pleaded not
guilty to all charges leveled against
them in the college admissions scam
[Music]